-Here's how it works.
One teammate will get a clue
and then they'll dance it out
on our disco floor
to get their partner
to guess what it is.
You'll have 90 seconds to guess
as many as you can.
Each dance move
is worth 1,000 points.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Darren and Sarah,
you are up first.
Patti, Billy,
you can have a seat
by the piano if you'd like.
-Alright.
-Okay.
Who's going to dance
and who's going to guess?
-I think I'm dancing.
-You're dancing?
Oh, yeah, you're walking
right out there.
You're ready to dance.
Alright.
-I'm moving.
-Right in the middle.
Okay, the category
is Schoolhouse Rock, okay?
So, these are things
inspired by elementary schools.
Let's put 90 seconds
on the clock.
Adam, can you give us something,
a little disco feel, please?
-Let's do it.
-Ahh!
-Time starts now. Go.
-"Saturday Night Fever."
Hopscotch.
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-Uhh...
Oh, sharpening a pencil!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-Uh...
Uh, dodgeball!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-Uh...
Erasing a board!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-Uh...
Jumping rope! Skipping rope!
Double dutch!
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, nice!
-You are...
Duck, Duck, Goose!
[ Ding! ]
-Aha! Nice!
-Kickball!
[ Ding! ]
Um...
Patty cake, patty cake,
baker's man!
[ Ding! ]
Uh...
What is it? Tug-of-war!
-Wow!
-Um...
The seesaw!
[ Ding! ]
-Oh!
-Tag, you're it!
-Wow!
[ Ding! ]
-Show and tell!
My God, he's so good at this!
Climbing a rope, a ladder!
Monkey bars! Handles!
Monkey handles!
[ Ding! ]
-Climbing rope in gym class!
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
-Dirt everywhere.
Playing in the mud!
Painting class!
You're eating the paint.
You -- Finger painting!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-Reading.
Uh, oral essay.
[ Clock ticking ]
-Honey, they did great.
-I know.
-You guys! My goodness!
You almost got all of them!
[ Ding! ]
Give them a standing ovation!
That was great!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Thank you. Thank you.
Nicely done.
-You were amazing.
-You can take your seats.
That was insane.
You got all of them.
Oh, my goodness.
-My goodness.
-Good luck.
Good luck to you guys.
I don't know what to say.
That was pretty perfect
right there.
-That was extraordinary.
-That was excellent.
-Alright.
-And, you know --
-Okay. Are you dancing?
-I think I'm dancing.
-You guessing clues?
-I'm gonna do my best.
-You'll crush it.
You're Patti LaBelle!
-We'll just...
-I know it's a competition,
but that was amazing.
-Thank you.
-Your category
is Smells Like Teen Spirit.
All of these clues
are inspired by high school.
-Oh, okay.
-High school?
-Yes. High school.
-I was there a long time ago.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on. We got it!
-90 seconds on the clock.
Can we get another disco track?
-Here we go!
♪♪
-Raise your hand.
[ Ding! ]
-There you go!
-Writing.
Oh, cheating.
[ Ding! ]
-Yes! Very nice!
♪♪
-Fixing your hair.
I don't know.
-Pass!
♪♪
-Cheerleader?
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
Falling asleep in the class.
-Yes! Very nice!
-Okay.
Dancing? Dancing with --
-Yes, that's good.
-Dancing with yourself.
What?!
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
-Pass!
[ Laughter ]
-What was it?
Um, uh...
Next! Next.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Teacher trying to get your
answer from the --
-Pass
-Pass, pass.
[ Clock ticking ]
-Playing the flute?
Playing a --
[ Thud ]
-That's it! That's it!
Thank you very much.
-Ohh, no.
-Get over here.
[ Ding! ]
Wow! Come here.
Come here. Come here.
-I think I may have forgot
to dance for some of that.
-No, you were great.
-Come here. Come here.
-Oh, man.
-You ever play Spin the Bottle?
-No.
-We got to play after the show.